[Applause]
uh jake paul
been asking oh yeah that was it was a
phenomenal press conference
the highlights were great son the
highlights were great did you see ben
askren's promo video
yeah i saw you retweet it fantastic
absolutely amazing
this guy's great at content he is great
and
even when he's calling jake yeah he
didn't call him jake paul he calls him
logan
paul's little brother yes and you know
that's the thing that yeah
oh i yeah dude of course i'll be honest
i think i think jake seemed a little
nervous
i think jake was just out trolled but i
still think jake is gonna win the fight
but i think he's not used to being on
the end where like a fighter is better
at that part than him
yeah i don't think he ever saw that
coming yeah yeah yeah that's a great
call that's a great call and that can
throw you off because you're like i'm
usually the one that like
is antagonistic and yeah i'm the [ __ ]
that gets under your skin how the [ __ ]
are you doing this to me i did not
see that coming yeah there was one point
where like he just didn't know what to
say and he's like
stupid [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
it was just you almost felt bad you're
like oh [ __ ] you didn't have a line yeah
that moment
so ben is under his skin oh yeah i
wonder if he goes out and tries to knock
him out too
hard and that works in ben's favor
i don't know i mean listen everybody i
know that knows boxing you
rogan that's about it they say he could
throw like this kid's legit nice at
boxing
no he's and ben is not nice you might be
good at fighting but not boxing he's
good the only
chance that ben has and it is a
significant chance
is having good enough head movement to
avoid
jake and one having a strong enough chin
and he has a [ __ ] excellent chin
okay he does have an excellent chin he's
been hit hard with the little four ounce
gloves
having enough chin to sustain punishment
until jake gets tired
because we don't know what jake's cardio
is gonna be like like it takes fighters
years to build up to an eight-round
fight like most fighters like i think
amateurs
are three rounds now there was time i
think there are four rounds like
and a lot of guys will fight four
rounders and build up to an eight-round
fight
eight rounds is a lot yeah and
ben has full fight cardio he has
five five minute round cardio if he
needs so if he can do five fives you can
do
eight threes i listen but it's different
you know boxing is also different we'll
see
but you like to you'd probably go okay
this guy's been fighting longer he's
been in the gym longer he's been doing
this for the last [ __ ]
decade and a half or whatever however
long he's been doing it the guy's
the guy's cardio is probably at a level
that's better and i think he's like i'm
just gonna try to wear jake down
and then eventually his cardio goes and
then i'll just beat him up and hopefully
get a stoppage
yeah so it's really about jake's cardio
and if jake is too excited and trying to
knock him out too quickly because he's
too angry he just really wants to expose
this guy that
has embarrassed him yep that cardio goes
how did his pad work look to you in that
promo video his pad work always looks
trash
that's what i was thinking it always
looks trash but it doesn't mean
that one he doesn't hit hard and two
that he's not gonna
uh be in there and engage in doing some
what they call like dirty boxing
like i think ben could get in there in
the clinch and then work out of the
clinch well
what does that mean oh the clinch is
like when they're kind of like holding
each other like in a phone booth they're
just real tight yeah so that's what i
think he'll do i think he'll kind of
like hold one arm and then hit him with
some upper cuffs maybe some overhang
right like
not technically legal uh it's not
technically illegal either okay
right it's just like in the gray area
right you're not gonna get a point
deducted
but uh because you can work inside but i
think that's where he's gonna feel more
more comfortable because he can also
control him there
yeah if he needed to he can wrap him up
and then once he wraps him up there's
nothing jake can do
right you're talking about an elite
wrestler yes there's nothing you
you just got to wait for the ref to come
in and separate you right because you
there physically there's nothing you'll
be able to do right this guy's like
ability to
manipulate your balance with his is next
level right okay
the guy couldn't even strike and he
would just dominate fighters for most of
his career
simply because of that right same thing
with like khabib like khabib doesn't
have to be good at striking because once
he grabs you
there's nothing you can do yeah like
when he said to jake at the press
conference he's like
if we were in an alley street and i was
homicidal yeah if i wanted i could do a
homicide on you yeah
like you know that too yeah that's a
[ __ ] that's kind of crazy
i could kill you if i wanted to yeah
a guy in rainbow sandals says that to
you yeah
you got to believe that if a guy in
sandals ever says
if i wanted to kill you right now in an
alley i could do that
yeah and jake was like come on but he
wasn't yeah
the best thing jay can do is just make
it about boxing right like i would even
lean in like yeah he kicked the crap out
of me and wrestling or do all of course
of course
you're in boxing you don't know how to
do that in this specific thing
i'm knocking your ass out this is not an
alley this is not an alley yeah this is
a ring
yeah do you think jake feels like he's
in over his head a little bit
no because i think he's [ __ ] people
up in the gym
because everything that i've heard he's
legit everything that i've heard and i
trust the guys that i've heard it from
my guys told me before the nate robinson
fight they're like yo
this kid is [ __ ] people up in la i
think that was in la
like legit people not professional box
but like
legit gym guys yeah he's [ __ ] him up
right not just like oh we had a spirited
sparring match he's [ __ ] him up
right so on paper everything should go
his way
but if he can't hit him if ben is
elusive enough
can't do damage if ben gets in his head
how big of a deal is that in boxing
it can't expose you because i know in
basketball if you're the free throw line
in your head you're [ __ ] but this is
different it seems like
it's different it can't expose you i
think man i think it came out
so i think it just makes you want to
knock them out
make you want to knock the person out
quicker and then you just exhaust
yourself and you only have so much fuel
in the tank
right eventually we run out of fuel yeah
and an eight round
fight is about fuel management
as you get into eight 10 12 it's just as
important to be able to
manage your output yeah as it is to like
have those skills
to be in there because you can have all
the skills in the world if you've got
two rounds in you you're [ __ ] done
look at conor mcgregor yeah and every
boxer goes in with a game plan
so if you get in somebody's head and you
get get them off their game plan now
they're just
scrambling yes and once you do that he
can't stop the [ __ ] talk in the ring
even ben asked him got to be running his
[ __ ] mouth in the ring
no i i don't even think he has i think
he has to treat him like a little kid
undermine him kind of tease him like
really
get him and if the most important thing
that he can do and this is hard to do it
but is like is flip the internet on him
because right now the internet is is
like jake is
the man and he's trolling everybody and
he's like he's almost six nine in
the boxing like the mma community right
so if ascrine can flip the internet
like oh [ __ ] oscar did this thing that's
better and now jake is looking silly
like him pushing his face i thought
meant that like jake got under ascrine
skin
because asgard never makes physical
contact
um like askgren's his whole thing is
like
why are we saying we're gonna fight each
other we're literally gonna do it for
money
in two weeks like i've heard him say
that to people yeah like i'm gonna
you're gonna get your chance you don't
have to yap right now about this
but when he pushed his face and then
walked away i was like oh [ __ ] is
jake under ascertain skin or did ashton
go i can
mush this guy's face and there's nothing
he can do to me
i thought it was this is yeah it was
like a publicity thing like here i'm
gonna shove his face
everybody's gonna talk about that he's
not gonna do anything
he can't like this this is the not the
boxing ring i wouldn't yeah
yeah it was cool to see jake's reaction
though like people criticized like he
just slapped his stomach
but his knee-jerk reaction was like pull
back and then react with a punch
like when most people are like attacked
when they don't know they just retreat
and they put their hands up and they
stop they kind of freeze hands up freeze
but his reaction was to move his head
back and then
counter yeah that was the knee jerk
reaction yeah that was interesting it's
pretty cool
yeah it's like to learn those instincts
he's only in boxing a few years
yeah yeah it'll counter with an open
hand
he can't [ __ ] the money up either yeah i
know but i'm saying
that's still if it's reactive though if
it's a knee jerk you're not thinking
you're just going
yeah yeah good point i i don't know i
just thought i always liked seeing like
what do people
really do in the moment like how are
they really gonna react yeah
and um he tried to lose counter yeah
look either way i'm [ __ ] excited
if jake is knocked out you think he like
goes crazy or even if you win
or loses on like technicality or
something like i don't really see ben
reacting negatively if he loses i think
he's just sort of like all right
whatever moving on
if jake lewis do you think he throws a
fit does he like go wild
i think he spirals a bit i
the thing is like in my interactions
and like i think most people's personal
interactions with with jake
he's like just the sweetest kid like
he's just a [ __ ] nice guy
so he understands how to play the
character and like hype things up
okay so i he was very like humble
after his defeat of nate robinson he's
like i hope he's okay and you know he
called me
out and blah blah blah like yeah so i
don't foresee him
like making a big stink about it if he
gets knocked out
like i think but if he does get knocked
out i don't see who he's gonna fight
again
um so that's where [ __ ] gets tricky like
he needs this to go well he needs
i mean if he wins it's going to be him
and conor mcgregor is going to be a
thing that would make a ton of money
well
if he knocks ascrine out the fight game
is his
the mere the mere feat of making the
amateur boxing world
as lucrative as the heavyweight boxing
world potentially like if he can pull
that off
that in and of itself is just like [ __ ]
good for you
you [ __ ] did it pick whoever you want
yeah
that's in the mma world yeah and then
fight them after that
yeah if he knocks out ascrine
i'll be honest with you if i'm conor i
stay the [ __ ] away
really why because you said conor can
box aspirin cannot so to me if i'm
connor and i
we don't know if conor wants it but it's
like i mean this is an amateur boxer i'm
essentially an amateur boxer yep
who cares i stay away if i'm connor
if he knocks out aspirin okay because
asrin
has been okay so asgrin has been in
there with guys that strike
it's not like he has it and he has a
chin so if you manage to knock out a guy
with a chin
then you got this guy's punching power
like the only time like asprin's been
like
significantly hurt in his career is when
he got kneed in the [ __ ] head
at full run yeah like jorge's knee
yeah which was by design but like
that never happens i don't want to call
it lucky because he did train it and
worked on it and predicted where he was
going to go he's going to shoot for the
for the double leg and he need him right
there but like
i'll take that not happening nine out of
10 times right yeah
pretty infrequent yes so the guy's got a
chin
he's dealing with bigger gloves so the
[ __ ] hurts less
and he knows how to avoid a punch he's
been in there with guys who punch
yeah and they haven't hit him enough to
knock him out
and they know he's only doing one thing
to them
right he's wrestling him yeah like it's
not like he's like this versatile
fighter he's going into every fight
going i'm going to grab
you i'm going to hold you i'm going to
put you down and i'm going to punch you
that's all right so i don't know
it's just hard for me to just go yeah
there's no way but like conor went
rounds with floyd and maybe floyd was
just like playing with him but like
yeah you say floyd is carrying him plus
karen floyd don't train for the fight
apparently he only just did like
push-ups and [ __ ] like that
and even then he just did whatever he
wanted with him like floy i think connor
like
has good head movement you know but like
he couldn't hurt floyd
he didn't have the power in the gloves
like it's really interesting connor is a
[ __ ] hard puncher at like 145 pounds
as a boxer like the hands just didn't
seem hard
it was really weird i don't know what it
is but the the punching power just
wasn't there
because there's so much more glove i
assume right yeah i guess but like
he caught floyd with a clean uppercut
like floyd i think lunged in and like
he caught him early just a clean
uppercut like hit him there's nothing
[Applause]